The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, welcome
everyone.
It's 8:05, well, 9:05.
So today's lecture and
discussion is about how to
make good problems, whether
it's on homework problems,
exams, even problems in class.
Its general principles that
you can use constructing
questions that you ask, so
problems broadly conceived.
Now why problems?
So problems are, I think, one
of the central ways of
thinking about teaching.
And I'll show you how problems
fit into the grand scheme of
this course, of rethinking all
the aspects of teaching.
So one way that I like to think
about teaching is called
backward design.
So this is a way of designing a
whole course, could even be
for a curriculum.
And doing problems is
one aspect of that.
So why is it called
backward design?
Well, it's backward from
the usual way.
So I'll show you what backward
is and then show you what the
usual way is.
So in backward design the
highest-level thing you figure
out-- not necessarily the first
thing you figure out,
but the highest level thing--
is your course goals.
And that then feeds to OK, if
those are your course goals
how do you know whether students
have reached them?
And that's problems.
Problems, tasks, projects,
whatever it may be, things
that students are going to do.
And so generally speaking,
things to do.
And then given that you've
operationalized the goals in
these problems what are you
going to do in class, so that
students actually are able to
do these kind of things?
OK, so that is backward
design because the
usual way is the following.
You say, OK, well, you have
a bunch of lecture notes.
Where do you have those?
Well, either the last person
who taught the course gives
you their lecture notes.
Or you just take the standard
book in the subject and you
just do the lectures one per
chapter or one week per
chapter, something like that.
And you just go through
in the order.
So in the usual way you
start with this.
And then you think oh, whoops,
oh yeah, I've got to make some
problem sets.
And oh, some exams.
Well, what have we done this
last couple weeks?
OK, that's what we're
going to do.
So the usual way is you
start with here.
And then you get here.
And you somehow never
get here.
The course goals are,
basically, to
get through the book.
Right?
That's the implicit
course goal.
But it's never explicitly
planned.
So that's a terrible way,
but the normal way
of designing a course.
So this is backward design.
So this is due to Wiggins
and McTighe.
OK, so here we're going to
be discussing this today.
So we're doing this first.
And then the next session
is this one.
And I think the session after
that is, what do you do in
class, interactive teaching
and things like that.
So why am I doing it
in this order?
Well, in the levels of
abstraction these
are the most abstract.
And this is the most concrete,
OK, what question I'm going to
ask students in class now.
And this is things like goals.
I want them to really understand
conservation.
They're really high level.
So I think if you start here, by
trying to figure out course
goals, I haven't found that
works very well for me because
it's too high level.
I can't think about course goals
in absence of actual
problems and things I want
students to be able to do.
So this has the right level
between concrete and abstract.
So it's actually where
I start my thinking.
Now, you may actually find you
want to start somewhere else
on the continuum.
But this is what I found
works quite well.
You start here, you
operationalize what your goals
are in the problems that you
think are interesting.
And then you look
at the problems.
And that sort of gives you an
idea of the course goals.
And then you think about
the course goals.
And that helps you think
of problems.
But I start here.
And then, once I have things
like that, then class time is
actually much easier to plan.
Because class often is going
to be problems like this,
related to this,
maybe shorter.
But it's easier to plan
here after that.
Whereas we start here, you
don't know, you're
back in the old way.
So I don't want to start here.
This is too abstract,
so I start here.
So that's why we're
doing this now.
And then next week we're
going to do this one.
Question?
AUDIENCE: So when you say
that you're setting
goals for your class--
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: So if you say that,
basically, setting the goals
for your class, or for
your own course.
So when you design your course,
basically you write
out some kind of goals
you want to reach?
So how do you then
do the problem?
Do you go in detail
before you've even
started the whole class?
Or do you do it that on
a week-to-week basis?
PROFESSOR: Oh, what do
I tell the students
about the course goals?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I mean, if you
say, OK, basically, you have
your goals and then you
design problems so you
can reach the goals?
But then do you also design
these problems before you even
start the whole lecture?
The whole semester?
PROFESSOR: Oh, well,
it's pretty rough.
I mean, usually the first time
you teach the thing it's too
abstract to design--
I find--
everything in advance.
Maybe that's my extrovert
nature, which is that I find
it hard to design things for
people I don't know.
If I don't know the audience I
don't even know what to say.
So I want to actually teach the
course one time at least.
So then the audience becomes
concrete for me.
So really, the first time
through the course nothing is
ever ideal.
And you're doing everything
on the fly.
But the second time through the
course, you can actually,
basically, make all the problems
ahead of time.
So the second time through the
course you actually refine
your goals and your
problems together.
So that shows you the structure
of where we are and
where we're going to
go and then later.
So this is two weeks from now.
Today, here.
So how do you make problems?
Well, the fundamental principle
is, again, deduced
by induction from what happens
with regular problems.
So if you remember, I gave you
an example earlier of the
results of standard
problem solving.
And I'll just remind you that
we're putting up the
percentages again.
OK, so after doing lots
and lots of standard
multiplication problems,
students were--
if you remember-- unable to
do the following problem.
So these 13-year-Olds and
17-year-Olds were asked to
estimate 3.04 times 5.3.
So here were the answers.
So they were given four
possible answers.
And they could also
not answer.
So this is no answer.
So that's the age 13.
So of the four possible
answers--
or let's say no answer is
possible as well-- so five,
they're 1% over 1/5 will
get the correct answer.
So that's a bit depressing.
So you think, oh, OK,
the 17-year-olds
are going to be better.
And they are, but they only
have 37% correct.
OK, so here is a serious
problem,
which is rote learning.
And that's the fundamental
thing to
avoid when doing problems.
So these students-- especially
the 17-year-olds--
were actually perfectly capable
of doing exactly
multiplication.
So on the same test they were
asked questions like multiply
2.7 by 8.32 and given just empty
space on the page to
multiply it out.
About 80% did it right.
So it's not that they don't
know how to multiply.
They just don't know what
multiplication means, which is
a far more serious problem.
I'd rather they knew what
multiplication meant and
didn't really understand,
didn't
really know how to multiply.
Because the algorithm you can
teach them later if they
understand what it means.
But if they don't even
understand what it means that
basically it's 3 times 5, so
it's got to be somewhere
around 16, they don't understand
what multiplication
means or the number
system means.
That's a far more
serious problem.
And that's produced by the
traditional kind of problems.
The traditional kinds of
problems are, generally
speaking, too low level
and can be solved,
to easily, by rote.
Even the complicated traditional
problems can
eventually be turned
into rote learning,
and that's the danger.
So the main goal in making
good problems is--
I would say--
how to make problems that
fight rote learning.
OK?
That produce long-lasting
actual conceptual
understanding along with
whatever else you're trying to
produce and teach.
But really, fight the rote
learning because that is the
fundamental problem.
So a way of thinking about
this is to categorize the
levels of thinking that you're
expecting of students when
you're asking them
to do a problem.
And for that there is work
from 50 years ago now--
which is still useful--
which is Bloom's Taxonomy.
So Bloom's Taxonomy--
let's see, when was it?
I think it was 1956.
I think it was '56.
I'll put a handout on the
website for you which
summarizes in one page.
But I'll summarize it
even shorter here.
So what is it a taxonomy of?
Well, when you read the title
the book, it's Bloom's
Taxonomy of Educational
Objectives.
And it's not really clear if
that's going to be useful for
anything at all.
Because you think, what
the hell is that?
So the shortest way of
understanding it is that it's
six levels.
And each level is higher than
the one previous to it in
terms of the level of thought
required of a student.
So it's not really
a strict order.
You can have really hard
questions that seem to be low
level just because they address
misconceptions.
But generally speaking,
it's a rough order.
So the order is knowledge
questions.
Those are things like define,
name, state, list, You know,
it's basically almost rote.
I mean, these are the kind of
problems that everyone would
agree are rote, state
the definition of
Newton's Second Law.
The second is comprehension.
So that's sort of like
knowledge but
it's a higher level.
So that's being able to grasp
the meaning of the material,
not just recite the facts.
But generally, that doesn't
include the idea of being able
to transfer it to
new situations.
That's where application
comes.
So can you apply the material
to something?
For example, often compute,
demonstrate, show that, those
are typical verbs that
are used when you
have application questions.
The next level is analysis.
So that's really trying to
understand the structure of
the material.
So things like diagram,
differentiate, infer, outline,
point out, identify,
distinguish, discriminate, all
those kinds of verbs com into
analysis kinds of questions.
Synthesis--
so this is breaking
things apart.
This is the ability
to put things back
together in new ways.
OK?
So design, explain, categorize,
create, revise,
rewrite, reorganize, devise.
And the highest level
is evaluation.
So judging the value of
material, for what purposes is
this good versus that good?
Explain, contrast, summarize,
support, recommend, evaluate,
criticize, appraise,
so generally
quite high-level skills.
So this is the taxonomy and
this is a higher level.
OK, so a useful exercise--
whenever you're thinking of
problems-- is to try to place
them on this.
Now it's not that you want
no-knowledge kind of questions
and you want only to ask these
kind of questions.
Because if you just ask these
kind of questions people will
not be ready for them.
And they're not prepared.
It doesn't actually
teach anything.
You want a mix of them.
But generally speaking, what
happens to often, is that most
of the questions that happen
are usually in this zone,
maybe a few of those.
And then only later in
people's careers do
they get over here.
For example, in engineering
curricula you learn a ton and
ton of application, maybe
comprehension, Maxwell's
equations, differentiation,
integration.
Then we start to synthesize
stuff.
You know, in your senior
year you do
design and project classes.
But you don't have to wait
all the way until then.
You can actually start putting
stuff in much earlier.
And it doesn't have to
be an entire class.
You can have tasks that are like
that in a short time, on
a problem set in the middle
of lecture time.
OK?
So questions about
Bloom's Taxonomy?
OK, so what I'll do, is I'll
give you an example of
questions that in freshman
physics mechanics--
on the topic of Newton's
laws--
that fit into each
of those levels.
OK, so just to give you an
example, to make it concrete,
to see what those kinds
of questions are.
And some of the categorizations
I'm going to
give you are debatable.
But the rough idea is that
they go from high to low.
So this is on the subject of
Newton's second and third law.
So a knowledge question, state
Newton's second law, state
Newton's third law, so you can
see, just because people can
state it doesn't mean they can
actually do anything with it.
That's why this is way up just
at the knowledge end.
Computers are actually
really good at this.
Right?
You can look it up on Google.
But your computer can tell you
what Newton's second and third
law are but you can't actually
do anything with them.
So comprehension--
so give an example of Newton's
Second Law, using Newton's
Second Law.
OK, this next one is
an application.
It turns out to be, actually,
quite a hard application.
But it's still an application.
So it's to apply Newton's second
and third law to show
the following, which the
following is suppose I have a
piece of chalk in my hand and
I stand on a weighing scale.
I want the students to show that
the weight that the scale
reads is equal to the sum of
the two individual weights.
So I weigh myself.
And then I put the chalk
on the scale.
And I add up those
two weights.
And that should be the
same as when I hold
the chalk in my hand.
OK?
So I'll diagram that as--
OK, so that's me plus chalk
equals me plus chalk.
So this is a scale.
OK?
So there is the piece
of chalk.
So now this is an example of
where that's quite a hard
application question, even
though it's kind of high up on
the Bloom's list, so towards
the lower end.
Because this is a serious
misconception
that students have.
Newton's second and Newton's
third law, people are
completely confused about,
you'll find.
They don't know when
to use which.
And they think any time two
forces are equal it's sort of
50-50, whether it's because of
Newton's third law or Newton's
second law.
So this-- if you're addressing
misconceptions--
makes the problem, actually,
all the much harder.
So at analysis--
so the analysis comes out--
oh, question sorry.
AUDIENCE: What are Newton's
second and third laws?
PROFESSOR: Ah, fair question.
So Newton's Second Law says
force equals mass times
acceleration.
Third law is--
the way it's usually stated,
which it's terrible--
action equals reaction.
Or for every action there's an
equal and opposite reaction.
Oh, which reminds me, one of
the questions from before,
which is what name
would I give?
Because I said I slagged off the
reaction force as the name
and the normal force
as a name.
People ask me, what should
you call it?
And I actually thought
about that.
And I think the answer
is contact force.
Because that tells you
what the thing is.
It's a force of contact.
So Newton's third law says
action equals reaction.
So now, the problem is that
students have, is that
whenever they see two forces
are equal they assume it's
because the action
equals reaction.
Or they think Newton's third
law is the reason for it.
So for example, the
bouncing-ball question that we
talked about last time.
So in the bouncing ball the
question is, when it's
stationary on the ground what
are the forces on it?
And they'll often say, well,
there's a weight downwards.
And there's the force upwards.
And they'll often say, well, the
force upwards equals the
weight downwards.
These are both forces
on the ball because
action equals reaction.
And they won't realize that
action and reaction have to be
on different objects.
OK?
So they're fundamentally
confused about the meaning of
action and reaction, which you
can bring out with the
following analysis question--
When two forces are equal in
magnitude how do you tell if
it's Newton's two
or Newton three?
So how do you know if it's
Newton two or Newton three?
So just ask them that.
Yes, question?
AUDIENCE: This might be a little
bit off subject, but
should we use Newton's
third law ever?
It seems like it's a natural
consequence from
saying a equals 0.
PROFESSOR: Ah, oh,
OK, interesting.
So OK, let me actually
explain that one.
I'll put it over there because
I didn't do the
boards right over here.
So that is exactly the issue
brought out by this question.
And let me show you
the difference.
And then there was
another question.
That reminds me of another whole
set of questions from
the sheets, which was
how do you develop
your physics intuition?
So let me answer that
in a moment.
After this and then we'll
have a break.
OK, so the bouncing-ball
question--
actually let's not do
the bouncing ball.
Let's just do an object
sitting on the ground.
Oh, great, can you
pass them around?
Oh, Leeann's just coming around
with a handout on
Bloom's Taxonomy.
And let's see, I'll do these
after the break.
OK, suppose you have this object
sitting on the ground
and it has Mass m.
OK, let's look at what
the forces on it are.
Well, there's mg down--
and actually, in this case, the
contact force, our normal
force is equal to mg.
OK, so now the question is, are
these two equal because of
Newton's Second Law or
Newton's third law?
That's what this
question asks.
So it's actually worth
understanding
the difference here.
So these guys are equal
because a equals 0.
So this thing's just sitting
on the ground, a equals 0.
So the net force is
0, so these two
forces have to cancel.
OK, so that's Newton's
Second Law.
So then the question is, where
does Newton's Third Law show
up in this?
Ah, Newton's Third Law
shows up here.
Here is the Earth.
And here is your object.
Let's just separate them just so
you can see them separate,
although this is sitting
on there.
So this is mg.
Well, this is the mg because
of gravity, right?
The earth gravity is attracted
to mass, m.
Well, the mass is also attracted
to the earth.
So what's the force on the
earth from the mass?
AUDIENCE: mg.
PROFESSOR: mg, it has to be.
Now this mg equals that mg.
Call this f2 and this is f1.
So f1 equals f2 by Newton's
third law.
So that's a fundamentally
different set of forces.
So are equal and opposite.
They're an action/reaction
pair.
So what Newton's third
law really says--
when you understand it-- is that
all forces in the world
come in pairs.
So if you ever see one force
you have to hunt around for
his other half.
And the other half
here is this.
So actually, there's another
question you could use for
Newton's third law.
So I don't have it
on the list here.
But I'll ask it right now, which
is suppose someone comes
to you and proposes the
following gravitational law--
f gravity equals g m1 squared
m2 over r squared when the g
is the proper units.
So m1 squared times m2,
is that a legal
force law for gravity?
No, because when you switch m1
and m2 as you're doing here--
you're switching the mass
and the earth--
you actually change the force.
So then this would violate
Newton's third law.
OK?
So Newton's third law, it
actually is a constraint on
the laws of physics.
It's actually conservation
of momentum.
And for momentum to be conserved
you can't have any
arbitrary law of physics
that you want.
Does that help clarify that?
AUDIENCE: Come up with a better
set of taxonomy for
describing it that doesn't lead
people-- it leads people
into thinking about that.
PROFESSOR: I know.
I agree.
So I think the terms
are very important.
So that's why don't like this
form, action equals reaction.
I actually would prefer it were
stated all forces come in
pairs that are equal
and opposite.
Right, and language does
have a powerful effect.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The technical
[? route's ?] obvious, just in
calling the novel force the
contact force, but that's not
refined enough.
Because both friction and
novel are contact force?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] constraint
force because it
could constrain into
the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's probably
a better name.
Yeah, I agree with you.
So the comment was that contact
force isn't quite
right because there's friction
force as well.
And that's also a
contact force.
And maybe a better name
is constraint force.
I think that is a better name.
OK, so let me finish this list
of two more examples of
Newton's Second and third law.
And then we'll have a break.
OK, synthesis.
So creating a problem using
Newton's second and third law.
So for example, this is
a problem like that.
But here I'm asking the students
to make one up.
And here is a very hard evaluate
question, which is
what, if any, are the limits of
validity of Newton's Second
and third law?
So that's, actually, a very
interesting historical question.
Interesting historically because
Einstein thought about
that question.
He wanted to know whether
Newtonian gravitation and
special relativity
were compatible.
And basically, they can't be
because of Newton's third law.
Because gravity should propagate
with some speed, not
the speed of light.
So you can't actually conserve
momentum right away.
Suppose the sun does
something strange.
Well, it takes a while
for the earth to
actually respond to that.
And it's in that intervening
time Newton's third law seems
to be violated.
So Einstein thought very
carefully about that question
and came up with his theory
of gravitation.
So this is quite a high-level
question.
But it's to show the whole range
of things you can ask
about the second and Newton's
third law as you
climb Bloom's Taxonomy.
OK, so what we're going to do
in the second part is we're
going to actually practice
rewriting a couple of questions.
And I'll show you a couple
more examples.
And seeing how we can make
questions worse and better,
because I find that's actually
quite a good way to get
practice with designing
questions is taking good
questions, making them bad,
taking bad questions and
making them good.
Both ways are useful.
OK, so we'll do that.
Let's say it's 9:04,
9:10 let's say.
So it's 904 on that clock.
So see everyone, sorry it's
10:04 on that adjusted clock.
So see everyone at
10:10 or 10:11.
And meanwhile, here are
the feedback sheets.
So I'll just put a bunch
in the two back things.
So when you come back
just grab those.
OK, so I'll just answer a
couple questions which I
promised to answer.
So the comment made by several
people about last week's
examples, say, of the rock and
the rolling was that oh no,
that showed me that my
physics intuition is
quite off, and bummer.
And so then if you're going to
teach it, how do you make
sure, well, A, how do you learn
to think intuitively
about these things?
And B, if you're going
to teach it
how do you make sure--
related to that--
you actually have the intuition
before you teach it.
There's two answers to that.
One is that it's very rare that
anyone ever achieved a
goal that they didn't
set out to do.
And then just happened
upon it.
So I would say that's true,
also, with developing
intuition in these areas.
You have to make it your goal.
So it's not going to just
happen by chance.
So then questions, OK, if
it is your goal how do
you go about it?
One way is anytime you do a
calculation, at the end of the
calculation ask yourself
this question.
So John Wheeler-- who was
Feynman's adviser--
he recommended the following
question, which I think is a
fantastic question.
So the question is if you could
time travel back and
talk to your earlier self what
one or two sentences would you
tell your earlier self before
they started solving the
problem that would make
the problem just
sort of flow smoothly?
OK?
So what sentence would you tell
your earlier, pre-problem
solved self?
So this is after you
solved the problem.
So that forces you to give a
insightful summary of what you
learned from the problem.
So it forces you towards the
intuitive way of reasoning.
And you'll find it's quite
hard at first.
Because you don't have the
intuitive library.
But at least it points you in
the direction to be going.
OK, now what else?
Well, in chemistry there's
various books that help
develop intuition.
They have all kinds of
intuitive reasoning
questions in them.
And some are quite good.
Some of the books
are quite good.
So the one in chemistry that
I like is called Voyages in
Conceptual Chemistry.
And in physics one of the ones
I like is called Thinking
Physics by Epstein.
I think Epstein's like that.
So what that is, is that's
basically, one
question per page.
And it's multiple-choice
intuitive reasoning question.
And they're about all kinds of
interesting physics, like why
do tea kettles whistle?
If you shake bottle of soda
up, why does it explode?
And so it's filled with really,
really fascinating
puzzles and ways of thinking.
And then with explanations.
So just by thinking about them,
reading the explanation,
trying to understand, OK, then
asking yourself Wheeler's
question at the end of reading
the explanation, even if you
didn't solve it, you can develop
a lot of intuition.
I don't know a good one
for math or biology.
And if anyone does, I definitely
appreciate any
suggestions.
OK?
But there are resources
in some fields.
And the other is just whenever
you find paradoxes go after
them and share them
with everyone.
And ask everyone you know,do
you know any
paradoxes I can work on?
That'll also developed
intuition.
OK, and then related to that,
one comment was I've noticed
that teaching is the best
way of learning.
How can you incorporate
that into a course?
So yeah, that's true.
So sometimes you just have to
accept that the first time you
teach the thing you're going
to be learning a lot.
So that's fine.
And the second time you teach
it, it'll be much better.
So you'll actually develop a
lot of intuition the first
time you teach a course.
So for example, I found when I
was a graduate student, I was
a teaching assistant for Physics
1A at Caltech, which
was like 801.
And I found I had
a huge number of
misconceptions about tension.
I just had no idea
what tension was.
For example, I thought
tension was a force.
And now that seems
ridiculous to me.
And it doesn't seem ridiculous
to you that's because you're
in exactly the same state I
was in before I was taught
physics 1A.
And I've got myself all in a
twist when I was trying to
explain it.
And I finally tracked it down
to actually, that particular
misconception.
So then I developed a bunch of
questions for myself, which I
also asked students
about tension.
So teaching is learning.
And then how do you incorporate
that into a class
for the students?
Well, you can ask them to teach
each other and argue
with each other.
So we'll talk about that
in the session
on interactive teaching.
But yeah, it is the best
way of learning.
And so if you can get the
students to do that as well
you'll be increasing
their learning.
And then the last question for
the moment was what's my
response to the following
article-- so it was in the
globe on February 15, 2009.
And it said, don't
open with a joke.
So it was summarizing a paper
called "Increased
Interestingness of Extraneous
Details in a Multimedia
Science Presentation Leads to
Decreased Learning." Journal
of Experimental Psychology,
December, 2008.
So they summarized that.
So basically, what they found
is that if you start with a
joke that's extraneous to the
material it actually decreases
the learning.
And that, I think, is
quite plausible.
So I recommend that you start
with something interesting in
the beginning.
But it should be related
to the material.
So the problem wasn't
the joke.
The problem was that
the joke wasn't
related to the material.
So the thing should
be interesting.
Because you want to
draw people in.
You don't want to conclude from
that article that you
shouldn't start with
some interesting.
But you should start with
something interesting that's
related to the material.
OK, so redesigning questions.
So here is an actual question
that we will redesign.
And I've left up the Bloom's
Taxonomy there.
So actually, I have a
bunch of questions.
We'll do a couple of them.
And we'll review, probably, one
of the questions we did
earlier, which is
about the cones.
OK, so the question to start
with-- and we're going to go
that way and that way--
is find the eigenvalues
of this matrix.
So for those whose linear
algebra is rusty, the
eigenvalues of a matrix so
a matrix, m, times some
eigenvector e is equal
to lambda times e.
So if there's some vector that
the matrix just brings back to
itself with some constant,
that's the eigenvalue.
And this is the eigenvector.
So eigen meaning
own in German.
So somehow this vector belongs
to the matrix.
It's said to be an eigenvector
of the matrix.
It's preserved when you hit
it with the matrix.
You get back the thing itself.
And in that way it belongs
to the matrix.
OK, so there are recipes
for computing it.
And so here the question is, I'm
asking students to use the
recipe for computing
the eigenvalue.
OK, so now I'm going to ask you
the following question,
which is to design--
well, first of all, where would
you say that guy goes?
It's sort of comprehension.
You know, it's basically
computing.
Maybe it's a bit
of application.
But it's basically
comprehension.
OK, so can we go lower on the
taxonomy towards knowledge?
Can we go higher towards the
higher-level reasoning?
Let's try to construct questions
on this end.
OK, so everyone understand
the thing to work out?
I'm going to ask you to try to
think of stuff that could be
put here and here.
So this is lower level
and this is higher.
Does anyone need
me to explain--
or want me to explain-- more
about eigenvalues or
eigenvectors?
OK, so find a neighbor or two.
And try to think of stuff
that can go in
this box or this box.
And generally, the higher-level
questions
requires more knowledge about
the material, which is one
aspect of their being
higher level.
You need a bigger margin of
safety when you're trying to
design them.
But don't let that bother you.
See what you can construct.
And you can use the levels on
Bloom's Taxonomy to try to
create some kind of questions
around it.
By the way, the answer to this
question, by the way, is i and
minus i, just in case
you are curious.
OK, so let's see what examples
you've come up with, so
related to this question.
Obviously, you'll change
it around some.
Let's say either side, this
side or this side.
Someone I haven't heard from?
Yes, can you tell
me your name?
AUDIENCE: Mike.
PROFESSOR: Mike, yeah?
AUDIENCE: What is
an eigenvalue?
PROFESSOR: OK, so what
is an eigenvalue?
Where would you put that?
AUDIENCE: Lower.
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah,
good question.
It depends where you
put this one.
This one is computing, which I
roughly put that somewhere
between comprehension
and application.
So right now I would say, we're
somewhere around there.
So your question is to
define eigenvalue?
OK.
I'm just short-handing
it as defined lambda.
OK, so that's one question.
OK, another question.
Can you tell me your name?
AUDIENCE: Wendy.
PROFESSOR: Wendy, yes?
AUDIENCE: So related to that,
is that you could put that
question higher.
If you asked them, what does
an eigenvalue mean?
If you word it differently
instead of [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, which may have
been what you meant as well
and I may have defined lambda.
OK, so you're saying, well, you
can actually ask them to
say, what does eigenvalue
mean?
OK, so how would you if they
know what it means?
So what would you look for
in something like that?
AUDIENCE: If they could describe
it to you, or maybe
tell you a problem in which it'd
be useful, in using it?
PROFESSOR: OK, so yeah,
let me write that too.
Create a problem that would
benefit from lambda, that
would need lambda.
OK, so for example
here, create.
That's gone pretty far down
towards synthesis.
I really should have flipped
the list around.
But synthesis is quite high
on Bloom's taxonomy.
So you're actually going
to create a problem.
It's like the Newton's
law example.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
instead of saying, again,
what does lambda mean?
You could say what do the
results from finding lambda?
What are the results
of that solution?
PROFESSOR: OK, so how does
it help you to know the
eigenvalues?
Is that the question?
AUDIENCE: No, I'm just saying
instead of the general asking
for the definition, what
does lambda mean?
What is an eigenvalue?
What does it mean?
But after having solved the
problem saying, what does your
answer mean?
PROFESSOR: Ah, OK, so even if
you ask them this first you
can say, OK, interpret
your answer.
Yeah, and that's
a-- generally--
very good policy.
So interpret.
and where would I put that?
Eh, interpret is somewhere
like analysis,
maybe a bit of synthesis.
But yeah, it's quite
high on the list.
So interpret, that's another
really key word.
In fact, it's often
neglected, right?
We just ask students to
solve the problem.
And wander, wander, wander.
They get the thing that
looks like an answer.
They put a box around
it and they're done.
But actually, you can massively
increase the level
of a problem just by adding
to the problem,
interpret your answer.
What does it mean, that
that's an eigenvalue?
And maybe they would say
something like this.
But even that would be better
than just having done the
computational procedure and
got an answer out of it.
Yes, can you tell
me your name?
AUDIENCE: Ben.
PROFESSOR: Ben, yes?
AUDIENCE: I might ask, does
that matrix have any
eigenvalues?
PROFESSOR: OK, so yeah, so
let's put it over here.
Right, so there what you're
doing is you're not presuming.
You're not key-wording
what they should do.
When you do this-- especially
if it's a
linear algebra course--
they've probably seen a bunch
of things like this.
Like in a calculus
course, integrate
these things by parts.
They just know I have to
integrate by parts, whereas
here you're at least
one step higher.
Because they don't know whether
there's an answer to
the problem or not.
And they have to think, well,
how do I know if they're
eigenvalues?
So there's actually one
intervening level of
sophistication.
Other suggestions?
Yes, Adrian?
AUDIENCE: Just give them two
numbers and say write a matrix
that has these as
the eigenvalues?
PROFESSOR: OK, so let me
continue the list over here.
OK, so create a matrix which has
the following eigenvalues.
So say lambda equals
2 comma 3.
So create a matrix,
create a meaning.
We're already high up in the
taxonomy toward synthesis.
And actually, I would even use
a related one, which is--
so create a real matrix with
eigenvalues i comma minus i.
So that one, is quite
related to this.
And this is the answer.
So it's quite a hard question.
Even if people can do this and
find i comma minus i, this one
is very hard because you're
asking to apply a constraint
that the thing be real.
So it's not just any matrix.
But it's that the
thing be real.
And then you have to really
understand quite a lot about
matrices to do that.
Yes, can you tell
me your name?
AUDIENCE: Scott.
PROFESSOR: Scott.
AUDIENCE: So, I was thinking of
a synthesis question which
would be is after multiplying
the item the eigenvector by
the matrix how is it rotated?
PROFESSOR: OK, so what is the
geometric effect on the
eigenvector of the matrix
on the eigenvector?
AUDIENCE: Right, but the
question is if they understand
what an eigenvalue is.
PROFESSOR: They should be able
to answer that right away.
Right, but it really tests for
understanding of what the
meaning is.
So it's another way of
approaching the question of do
they understand eigenvalue
means?
What is the geometric effect
of the matrix on the
eigenvector?
And then hopefully, they'll be
able to say well, actually, it
doesn't rotate it.
It just scales it.
And the eigenvalue is the
amount of scaling.
OK, and that demonstrates
quite a high level of
understanding too.
And This is one reason that
oral exams, generally, are
quite good ways of evaluating.
Because you can ask these
kind of questions.
And as soon as you see that they
understand you move on to
something else.
Which of the flip side is that's
why oral exams are very
disconcerting for
the students.
Because you spend no time on
the things they understand.
Right?
So as soon as you know they
understand it, you move on to
something else.
So the student just feels
like, what the
hell happened to me?
I was doing fine.
And they asked me about
something else.
Yeah, that's exactly right.
That's why they asked you
about something else.
They knew there was nothing
more here to find out.
You understood it.
But that's why oral exams
are such a good way-- so
efficient--
for evaluating.
So in Cambridge we used to do
oral exam interviews for
admission for undergraduate.
So people would be admitted
to the major right away.
So we had two 20-minute
interviews.
And we found those were much
more reliable than all the
exams that they did in
high school, the
equivalent of AP exams.
Because you could really ask
questions that really probed
understanding and right away see
what people could do and
couldn't do.
So geometric effective of m on e
creating a matrix, so you're
asking, so what's the
geometric effect?
It's not just comprehension.
You're asking them to apply
it and maybe, in a
bit in a new area.
They hadn't really thought of
eigenvalues and eigenvectors
as geometric at all.
And now, all of sudden, you're
asking them that.
You're asking them to transfer
their knowledge, which is one
of the fundamental goals.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Once you give them two
matrices that has the same
eigenvalues you can ask them
to see if they are
related in some ways.
PROFESSOR: Right, so for
example, let's do this one.
So how are those two
matrices related?
So they both have eigenvalues
i and minus i.
This one obviously does because
those are the diagonal
values and there's
nothing else.
And this one, you have to do
it by the magic procedure.
You don't have to.
And so how are they related?
So that is some kind of
analysis question.
And it's quite a difficult
It tests for really, do they
understand what matrices mean?
So that's why I've underlined
this word.
The questions all in this column
are all somehow testing
that they understand
what things mean.
So that ties back to the point
I made earlier, which is that
the whole fundamental point of
asking good questions is to
avoid rote learning.
Is that by asking good
questions you're
fighting rote learning.
And rote learning is the
bane of most education.
Right?
Rote learning is too often
the result of education.
And it's the-- in my view--
fundamental problem
with education.
So by asking questions that are
different you're actually
starting to fight that
and break the habit.
So for example, how does
rote learning show up?
Well, in the bouncing-ball
question, so the force is-- in
the instant that it's
stationary, while it's bouncing--
people say mg.
While this mg is right.
The gravity, but the contact--
let's say the constraint
force--
in this case it is a very
full-contact force is mg.
One of the reasons they say that
is the misconception that
they think a equals 0
because v equals 0.
So that's one reason.
But the other reason is that
they've done so many problems
with books resting on tables,
balls resting on tables, where
the force is mg.
Right?
So they've now induced a new
rule of physics, let's call it
Newton's fourth law.
That anytime you see a contact
force it is mg.
So contact force equals mg maybe
times cosine of theta.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Right?
or sine theta.
I guess it's mg--
well, it depends how
you measure theta.
But theta is the tilt
of the plane.
So if the plane is tilted 0
degrees just to ground, well
it's then mg.
So that kind of learning is the
result of rote learning
because they've solved problems
without understanding
what they mean.
So instead of figuring out that
oh, actually, you could
understand it from Newton's
Second Law and understanding
acceleration, they think oh,
there's a new pattern here.
Right?
Oh, a new pattern is whenever
I see contact forces it's mg
times maybe cos theta
or sine theta.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What's the exact
question with that system and
what's the normal [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so the question
was so you drop the
ball, say from here.
And when it bounces off the
steel table there's one
instant when it's stationary
on steel table.
And what are the forces
on it at that instant?
AUDIENCE: I remember
from last week.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, no,
fair enough.
I should have stated the
question out again.
So this is stationary
for an instant.
All right, so actually the ball
is quite compressed here.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Isn't it impossible
to give an exact answer for
the force with the [INAUDIBLE]
if you don't have
the duration?
PROFESSOR: It is, right.
So it is impossible to give
the exact answer.
But what you ask them is, well,
how big is it roughly?
So I always protect myself
by saying roughly.
And then you can ask
anything you want.
And because, really, all I'm
interested in is do they think
it's 1 times mg or do
they realize it's 10
to the 4 times mg?
And those are so far apart
that I don't care about
factors of two or three
or even 10.
Now, how can you know that it's
10 to the 4 times mg?
Well, that is quite
a hard question.
That's way down there.
Even though you'll see some
lists of Bloom's Taxonomy say
estimate is a low-level
skill, not that
high in Bloom's Taxonomy.
It's almost like computing
somewhere in comprehension.
I don't agree with that.
Because as you saw from the
example where students
couldn't estimate 3.04 times
5.3, they're terrible at
estimation.
So estimation actually hits one
of the big misconceptions
and reveals a lot of
the misconceptions.
So I put estimation almost at
the level of synthesis because
it forces you to really
synthesize your understanding.
You can't hide behind
formulas.
So the next thing I'll do is
say, OK, let's estimate this
and see if you can do that.
And if they really understand
the system they
can estimate it.
But it's quite hard.
And I find almost no students
can do it on their own.
But the method of estimation is,
as you say, you do need to
know the contact time.
So the acceleration is
not 0 as you say.
But it's delta v over delta
t, where delta t
is the contact time.
Well, it's going v and then it's
pretty much going v up,
so that's about 2v.
But I don't care about
factors of 2.
And then, what's the
contact time?
Well, there's a couple methods
for doing the contact time.
One is you listen
for the pitch.
And whatever the highest
frequency in the pitch is--
suppose it's 10 to
the 4 hertz--
well, then 1 over that time,
1 over the frequency
is roughly a time.
So it's probably the
contact time.
So that's one approach.
The other approach is to say
well, actually, physically
what's happening?
The ball is hitting
the bottom.
And this end compressing.
But this end keeps going.
Because it has no knowledge that
the bottom of the ball
hit the ground.
How's it going to
know about that?
Well, the bottom of the
ball has to tell it.
How's it going to tell it?
Well, it has to send some
kind of signal.
How does it send signal?
Sound.
So it sends a sound
wave upward.
And the sound wave travels in
steel about 5 or 10 kilometers
per second.
So you suppose it's a
5-centimeter ball, then it's
about 10 to the minus 5 seconds
is your contact time.
So this is really short.
So suppose v is something like a
meter per second, and divide
it by 10 to the 5 seconds.
You're talking about something
like 10 to the 5 meters per
second squared, which is 10 to
the 4 times the acceleration
due to gravity.
OK?
So I went through because I
think it's interesting but
also to show that estimating
actually requires generally,
very high-level skills.
And it's quite hard
for the students.
Therefore you should do it.
So there are some people who
say, well, it's very hard for
the students.
Don't do it.
But again, there's another rule
of thumb in teaching,
which is nobody ever learned
anything that you didn't
actually try to help
them with.
Well, that's not quite true.
But if you never teach something
they're not very
likely to learn it.
So if it's something hard but
valuable you have to start
teaching at some point,
which is why I put
up that graph earlier.
Oh, it's gone now.
Where in the earlier stages of
teaching you do things more
approximately.
And then in the later stages
you do it more exactly.
So what I've told you
now is a slight lie.
So this brings up the
question from last
time, what about lying?
Is it useful?
Yes, it's essential because this
argument is simple enough
that once you understand
it you can just
keep it in your head.
And it's a bit of a lie, the
reason being that the ball
doesn't have a uniform
cross section.
So as the ball compresses the
contact area changes, whereas
if the ball were cube or a rod
the contact area would stay
the same as it compressed.
So there's a correction
factor because the
contact area changes.
Now, that correction factor
is not very big.
It turns out to be the
fifth root of some
dimensionless thing.
And so this sound-wave argument
you put in to the 4/5
power and then you put in the
other thing to the 1/5 power.
So it's almost correct for
this spherical ball.
So in a later of course
it actually
adjusts for that factor.
And then in a much later course,
probably, what I would
do is calculate the exact 2 pi
over whatever factor that
shows up as well, by way of
increasing the symbolic
complexity.
But even this estimate, doing
that is conceptually hard.
So I would say start
that early.
AUDIENCE: I think the point
I was trying to
make was that this--
I suspect that the students
answered that wrong because of
real problem solving, and that
they expect there to be a
solution given the data
that you [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, if you've
worked with them a bit on
estimating they know that
they're going to have to do
some thinking.
If you say compute the force
I agree with you for sure.
They're going to think they have
to be able to do it from
the data there.
And they'll just say it's got
to be mg because that's the
only other force I know.
But if you say estimate then
there is a bit of a queue that
they have to include some other
information which might
not put in the problem.
And so that mitigates
the rote learning.
But what I find, even then, is
they usually still can't do it
because their misconceptions
about acceleration are so deep
and about equilibrium
and force.
They think f equals
mv, basically.
OK, so let's just look at
what we've done here.
So I would say you can
define lambda.
You can define eigenvector.
You can even say state the
computational procedure.
I'm not sure where
I would put that.
Depending on how people learn
it, this could be purely a
knowledge question.
Because people could state the
procedure but not really
understand it, not be
able to do anything.
Or actually, you could say
program the procedure.
Well, that would be something
over here probably.
Because to program it you
probably have to understand
what you're doing pretty well.
So stating the procedure, it
depends how you ask them to
state it, whether it's
a low-level or
a high-level question.
So I'll put program over here.
OK, so we've gone down and up.
And again, I want to remind you,
I'm not saying all your
questions need to be here.
But generally, the questions are
too much over here and not
enough over here.
So this gives you a recipe for
thinking of new questions.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So throughout the
course do you basically, maybe
start on the first three in
the beginning and then you
move it more through until you
reach the end of the course?
PROFESSOR: More fractal.
The question was as the course
moves on do you move more
towards synthesis?
I actually try to
make it fractal.
So within each unit and each day
even, I try to maybe have
something, knowledge or
comprehension just to make
sure everyone's tracking.
But try to have something
interesting as
well, all the time.
So something synthesis,
analysis, maybe some evaluate.
And so each problem set--
for example--
I'll put, generally,
warm-up questions.
So basically they're marked warm
up so that people know
OK, those are going to be
knowledge and comprehension.
And you need that.
Because otherwise there's no
point trying to do synthesis
if you don't have the
base knowledge.
But just make sure you
understand those,
just in your sleep.
And then regular problems, which
tend to be somewhere in
the middle, say application
or analysis.
And then bonus problems which
are just optional.
But they're for people who
either find all the other
problems easy or are
really curious.
For them I put either synthesis
or evaluation.
For example, in the
approximation class the last
problem set had design an
email indexing system.
So that was the bonus problem.
And there was a bunch of warm-up
and regular problems
which were involving Unix
text processing.
And then for the people who are
really curious actually,
put it all together and make a
really fast email-indexing
system so you can just find any
email that you want just
by doing keyword search.
Sort of like a web search but
just on your email inbox.
Because I actually
use that myself.
Because I find folders
are just hopeless.
It just takes all my time.
I have to figure out what
folder things are in.
And that could be many.
So I just keep it all in one
giant inbox with, I think,
150,000 messages in it.
And I just search
through that.
And I have an index that's
rebuilt every week or so.
And so I can search through
it really fast.
So it's actually very practical
problem and it gives
you an example of the levels
of things you can ask.
So try to do it on
a fractal scale.
Each class should have
something, mix the levels each
homework, the exam.
So the general rule is to
mix them up all the way.
OK?
So hopefully, from that, you
feel confident that you have
tools that you can make
interesting questions.
And this does have lots of
payoffs, which one of them is
that questions that are
enjoyable and educational,
students love them.
So when I practiced what I
preached and made these kind
of problems, mix of problems for
my classes, often students
have said, oh, can you please
have more problems?
Which is very rare.
They said, oh, these are some
of the most interesting
problems I'm likely
to get at MIT.
And I used to read them
out in my living of my
independent-living group just
so that other people could
hear the interesting problems
and we'd try
to solve them together.
And then I've had several emails
after class finished,
saying, oh, you promised to post
the optional problem set.
Where is it?
So it's because the problems,
actually, somehow connect to
things that people find
real and interesting.
So that's a mix of
the perceptual.
Don't make it just purely
symbol manipulation.
Try to connect to ways people
look at the world.
But also, try to connect to
higher-level reasoning skills.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Do you always
use bonus problems?
PROFESSOR: I do.
I find that works really well.
Because it's like a
pressure-escape valve.
It caters for the diversity of
backgrounds in the class.
The people who are feeling very
worried by the material,
they can just skip
them, no problem.
And they don't feel like
they have to do them.
And they don't feel like, oh
my god, I can't do them.
I'm going to get points off.
And the people who find the
other stuff easy, they find
something for them too.
So yeah, I try to always
use bonus problems.
And I learned that from Knuth's
book, called Concrete
Mathematics.
So actually, I think they have
five levels of problems at the
end of every chapter.
There's warm ups.
There's homework problems.
There's exam problems,
bonus problems,
and research problems.
So the research problems
were the ones
that are not yet solved.
So at least you know they're
not yet solved.
So you're going to be spending
a while on them.
And then in the second edition
I think some of them were
actually solved.
OK, so if everyone could just
take a one minute and fill out
the feedback sheet?
Oh yeah, and let me just say,
why I'm doing this now at
10:50, of the questions on the
sheets before was the feedback
sheet, the person said, I've
been using them in my class
and they've been
really useful.
But I find that the response
rate has been dropping.
What do you do about that?
And I have to say, that I
found the same thing.
This year I found
the same thing.
Not in this class but in my
other class, whereas I didn't
find that last year.
And I was trying to
figure out why.
And theory I have is that I was
trying to put in too much
material in the class and not
leaving the students time
before the five-minute mark
to fill out the sheet.
So one thing, I've been trying
to mend my ways and make sure
I end class at 9:50 or 10
minutes to the hour so the
students have at least one or
two minutes to fill out the
sheet without feeling
pressured to get
to their new class.
So I'll let you know how that
goes over the next week.
So take a minute now and then
that'll maybe make you think
of some questions which
we can answer in
the next two minutes.
And then while you're doing
that, just a couple
announcements.
So sorry I didn't say anything
before about what to do with
the equation treatments that
you shared with each other.
So just discuss them
with each other.
You have a collaborator.
And then revise your treatment
based on what
that person told you.
You don't have to turn in
your revised treatment.
You guys are all graduate
students, or
almost all of you.
You're all taking the class
because you're interested.
I'm not trying to
police everyone.
But the goal here, and what
you should do, is take the
benefit of the collaboration,
revise your equation
treatment, and share
it with each other.
And then just bring in your
original one next week.
And then I'll also have a couple
of readings for you to
do for next week.
And also a short problem to work
on, things to think about
to bring in next week as well.
OK, so sheets and
then questions.
Question?
AUDIENCE: So I tried doing these
sheets for a class that
I was teaching yesterday.
In fact, I found that I got
a response rate of 15%.
If your response rate from the
beginning's very low and
[INAUDIBLE] to increase
that rate?
PROFESSOR: Right, so 15%, yeah,
I find I'm getting that
around now too.
And I think what's happened is
that I've got people in the
habit of not filling them out
because I wasn't giving them
enough time.
So I may be hosed because now
they're in the habit.
So I'm trying to mend it.
And I'll let you know if that
fixes it by giving people
actual time before
they feel rushed.
But it may be too late.
And I worry that
it is too late.
Because last year I was actually
more diligent about
making sure they had time.
And I found the response rate
stayed about 60%, 70%.
But even I find the
15% very useful.
And I found that--
people even in the past, when
the response rate was 30% in
another class people said,
I didn't have a
question all the time.
But I knew when I did
I could ask it.
So even the 15% isn't bad.
It's still useful.
But yeah, I would like
it to be higher.
And I'll tell you
how that goes.
Question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
Wiggins and--
PROFESSOR: McTighe, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Oh, McTighe.
Where are they based?
PROFESSOR: So where are they?
They're in New Jersey, and
they actually consult on
educational course design and
run workshops and courses.
And we actually invited
Wiggins last
year to come and speak.
So I'll put a short reading
selection from their book
called Understanding By Design
for optional reading for
people so then you can learn
more about that.
I find the basic form that
they say very useful.
I find applying it the way they
describe, sometimes I
just can't square it.
But it may resonate with
you quite well.
And the overall approach
resonates very
strongly with me.
So hopefully you will
like it too.
So I'll put that on the website
and some readings for
next time about course design.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Just a comment,
actually on your web page,
where the response
sheet [INAUDIBLE]
and situation where only a few
people were very dislike the
current [INAUDIBLE].
They don't like it this way and
so they want to change it.
But the 80% who don't
feel [INAUDIBLE] is
actually OK with it.
[INAUDIBLE] the change.
It makes most people unhappy.
PROFESSOR: Unhappy, right,
so that can happen.
And so that's the silent
majority problem.
So what I do when I get comments
like people saying,
well, I wasn't happy
about this.
Sometimes what I do is--
especially if it doesn't
resonate with my intuition
about how things were
going, and I thought
they were going well--
I'll say, well, there were a few
comments about this issue.
What do people think?
And just take an informal
straw pole
before I make big changes.
AUDIENCE: I think it helps to
have a positive question on
[INAUDIBLE], like,
what did you take
away from this lecture?
Or what did you really
understand?
PROFESSOR: Right, I think
that's right.
It helps to have a positive
question.
So that's why I say, either what
you take away, or what
helped or hurt?
So there's an opportunity to
say something helpful.
And any other comments is also
interpreted in a positive way.
Answers from Lecture
5 to questions
generated in Lecture 4.
PROFESSOR: OK, and questions
from last time.
So they grouped into
several ones.
One is how should you choose
your levels of your problems--
say, in class or in homeworks--
among the
different levels of
Bloom's Taxonomy?
Should it be, for example all
towards the evaluation?
So your side would be here,
sort of the high level.
A Mix?
A flat mix?
Should it be peaked towards the
middle with some tails?
So that depends, partly,
on your course design.
So to answer that question, you
can't really answer that
question until you figure out
what your course goals are.
So in some ways there's an
argument for doing course
design first and then working on
what problems to do and how
to design problems.
But actually, I like the
other way around.
I like doing course
design second.
Because actually, doing problems
is concrete enough to
do something.
And then it leads to questions
about course design, which
we'll answer how to
mix the levels.
OK, another one was several
people wanted to know, why is
tension not a force?
Or in fact, maybe is a force.
So let me explain that.
Because that actually gives you
another example of sorting
out misconceptions.
So it's always useful.
So I'll show you the sequence
of questions I used with
myself when I finally
convinced that
tension wasn't a force.
And here's how I did it.
And then I used the same
sequence of questions with
students to fight the
misconception that's been
induced by many pictures of--
for example-- a pulley.
And here's a rope and
there's tension.
Sorry, this is actually
done the other way.
So here's the rope.
And there's a t labeled there.
And then on the mass there's a
force labeled as t upward.
So when you see that you think,
oh, tension's a force.
So you see that a whole bunch
of times and you're pretty
sure of it.
So the sequence of questions
is as follows--
say OK, here's a tree.
And I'm going to tie a rope to
the tree, rope or a string,
it's a mass-less thing.
And I put a force on it.
OK, so I'm going to
pull that tree.
The tree's not going
to go anywhere.
We're going to pull
on the rope with
100 newtons of force.
OK, so you can try this
yourself too.
What's the tension
in the string?
OK, so take 30 seconds and
I'll take a tension.
OK, a tension, anyone?
AUDIENCE: 100 newtons.
PROFESSOR: OK, so in fact
that is 100 newtons.
And most people will
say 100 newtons.
OK, so now the next
question is this--
here is a river and
here's a rope.
And me and a friend each pull on
the rope with 100 newtons.
OK?
OK, so discuss with
your neighbor--
a, b, or c, what's the
tension in the rope?
And we'll take a vote.
OK, so take 10 seconds,
get your vote ready.
We'll take a quick straw pole.
Who votes for 0 newtons?
Who votes for 100 newtons?
Who votes for 200 newtons?
OK, so now here, how do you know
what it's going to be?
Well, you make a
force diagram.
And there's a way to convince
yourself that there's no doubt
about what it should be.
And we just draw the forces
on the rope here.
Oh, we've already done that.
Let's draw the forces on
the rope up there.
Well, what are the forces
on the rope here?
Well, it's 100 newtons
from you.
But there must also be 100
newtons from the tree.
All right?
So in fact, these two situations
are identical.
So yeah, 100 newtons seems
pretty clear here.
So it has to be 100 newtons
up there too.
OK, now that--
so far-- isn't the hard part.
But now is when you actually
create the contradiction with
the idea of it being a force.
It can't be a force because if
it were a force you would just
add up vectors.
Right?
So there's a couple answers
you get if it was a force.
If you're a bit sloppy you'd
just add up the magnitudes and
get 200 newtons.
If it's really a vector--
you're putting two vectors
on it, two forces--
you should get 0 because they're
two opposite forces.
But actually you get 100.
The only way to get 100 is that
the tension has to be
something completely different
from a force.
So that's how you know
it's not a force.
But how do what it is?
Well, it turns out
to be a tensor.
So it's not a vector.
Forces are vectors.
It adds differently
than vectors do.
It adds like a tensor.
So tension is more
like a pressure.
It doesn't have a particular
direction.
Pressure is in all directions.
So things like that, they can't
be described by vectors.
So you need something else.
And that's why we introduced
tensors.
So now, in freshman physics I
wouldn't give them a whole
story about tensors.
But I do actually teach this
much of it so that they know
that is a different object.
And then what do I
do about this?
Well, I won't write t unless
it's for myself.
But for the students I think
it's sloppy and it increases
misconception.
It's much better to write the
force sub t, which is the
force due to tension.
OK?
So even a slight change like
that can mitigate the rote
learning, where people think
oh, tension's a force.
Because you always see it drawn
like every other force.
There's mg down, There's t
up, must be a force too.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: What are the two
objects you hit it with to
make a scalar?
It's the two directions
that you're
interested in, basically.
So it would be the x direction
or the direction along the
string and the direction
along the string.
AUDIENCE: So it's the
two direction then?
PROFESSOR: You can use the
same direction twice.
So it's the direction
along the string
and along the string.
There's no cross direction.
So it has no shear.
So there's no cross direction.
So it's some component, tension
is one component of
the stress tensor.
So now, again, freshman don't
need to know all the details.
This is back to the subject of
lying they do need to not be
told fundamental lies.
Like for example, tension
is a force.
OK, so now, how do you deal with
misconceptions that show
up on problem sets?
This is a good question.
So the point was made well, in
class you can sort it out
right then.
Suppose you ask a question, say,
about the Ideal Gas Law.
And you find that people have
confused the Ideal Gas Law and
the Adiabatic Gas Law.
Well, you can talk about it
right then, which is a good
reason to do those
things in class.
What happens on the problem
set if you find there's a
bunch of misconceptions?
Well, one thing is, the first
time you do the problem set,
yeah it's a bit of a problem.
Because you don't know what the
misconceptions are unless
you've researched
ahead of time.
But the second time you do the
class you know what they are.
So you can address the
misconceptions in
the solution set.
So when I'm not totally sleep
deprived I always try to get
the solution set out the exact
same day that the problem set
is turned in.
So the students can
right away see.
They can turn in their problem
set, pick up a solution set or
look at it online.
So they can right away
get quick feedback.
And they can sort out the
misconceptions that way.
So that's a good question.
So it is harder.
Yes, question?
AUDIENCE: What do you do about
the fact that a lot of people
will just ignore the
solution sets?
Or do you just consider
that their problem?
PROFESSOR: So the question is,
what do I do about people who
just ignore the solution sets?
Because a lot of students
do that.
Yeah, partly I consider
it their problem.
Because look, that's there
for them to learn.
But partly, to the extent that
they're ignoring the solution
set because they only cared
about the grade.
So one cause of that
is they really only
care about the grade.
So they just want to wait for
the grader to give them back
their solutions, their problem
set with a mark on it.
And they don't care what's
right and wrong.
That, I think, partly, is our
responsibility that we've
chosen boring problems.
So to fix that, I think, one
of the key areas is to use
more of the Bloom's Taxonomy and
make interesting problems.
And the flip side is to
deemphasize the grading.
So actually, I like the
PDF scale on homework.
I think we are too
micromanaging, generally,
about homework, you know,
grading it on a percentage
scale, on A, B, C, D. P,
you did a reasonable.
And D, you blew it off.
You did something but
it was a joke.
And F, you didn't turn it in.
I think that scale puts the
right emphasis on the grading.
Look, we just want you to
do the thing and try it.
And if the problems are
interesting that allows people
to actually get involved
in it.
So there's lots of studies that
show that if you reward
people for things they
already enjoy--
so you start paying them more
for doing things they really
like-- they actually start
liking them less.
So I'll talk about that as one
of the political barriers to
educational change.
Because that's completely
against the conventional
psychology of this society,
where everything has to be
rewarded, merit-based pay
and this and that.
So how do you go against that?
It's quite difficult.
But one way, in general, in
those problem sets is to
deemphasize the grading.
Related method--
which I haven't tried yet
but I'm planning to--
is reading memos on
the solution set.
So I talked about reading
memos before.
And maybe one of you will try
it before me and can tell me
how it works.
A reading memo is--
I talked about-- where you
have the students take a
reading and mark--
either online or
on a piece of paper--
things that were confusing or
things that were interesting
and things they noticed.
Well, you can do that with
the solution set too.
You say, OK, your assignment,
homework 3A is to look at the
solution set for homework
two and mark
anything that's confusing.
So that forces people to
read the solution set.
And often what you'll find is
that they'll find mistakes in
the solution set, which is good
to know because you can
correct them right away.
But you'll see what parts are
confusing to students or not.
Did that help answer
your question?
Great.
Do I ever asked Wheeler's
question explicitly?
Yes, sometimes.
I should do it more in
class in lecture.
But I do it a lot to myself.
Whenever I solve a problem
I think oh,
what was the key idea?
And then once I see the key idea
happen many times I think
oh, that's a very key idea.
That should be taught
explicitly in class.
So I do that.
And I'm going to talk about
that principle of course
design today, basically
organizing courses around
large themes and principles,
which is one of the main
[? cures. ?]
OK, so what's wrong with
tension as a force?
How far should I go
down the taxonomy?
Basically, where in the
course should I be?
Really low in the taxonomy
early and higher later?
Well, I talked about that
a bit last time.
The fractal picture
is not bad.
So yeah, you have a few
low-level examples and
higher-level examples.
But you do that throughout
the course.
So you don't wait until the end
of the course to get the
reward of the really interesting
problems.
And then related to that, what
about exams and homework?
Should they be the same
or different?
My view is they should be the
same given the constraint that
maybe the exam is done
in a shorter time.
So if anything, the
exam should be
easier than the homework.
Generally, homework people
will spend six
or seven hours on.
When I was an undergraduate
we had take-home exams.
And we would spend
24 hours on them.
You pick them up, you
signed it out.
You'd turned it in
in 24 hours.
So that was misery.
And it was interesting.
You learnt a lot.
But it was kind of miserable
because it just wiped out a
whole day from your quarter.
And you had that for
four classes.
So four days from your quarter
were just gone.
So generally, exams are three
hours, maybe two hours.
And so that's much less time
than a homework set.
So if anything, exams
should be easier,
definitely not harder.
Student loath when the exam does
different things than the
problem sets.
And that is a general principle
of course design,
that if you want to prepare
them for being able to do
stuff-- for example
on the exam--
you have to prepare
them with things.
You have to "teach to the test."
That's actually good.
You want your homeworks
to be like the exam.
And that's fine if
the test is good.
If the test tests real-world,
interesting skills sure, then
it's fine to teach the test
because they'll come out being
able to do that, no problem.
So the exam and homework-- as
a rough rule of function--
will be pretty much the same.
Or if anything, the exam
should be easier.
Oh yeah, the first time
you teach a class.
So all this Bloom's Taxonomy
and designing questions, it
takes a long time.
And it's really hard to
make good questions.
It's easy to make define
XYZ questions.
But what about the higher-level
questions?
What do you do to mitigate
that problem of a
huge amount of time?
Well, one of the cures is to
cooperate with other teachers.
So you steal their
good problems.
So I gave you the T.S. Eliot
saying before, that talent
invents and genius steals.
So be a genius.
Whenever you see a good
problem just use it.
And whenever someone wants
a good problem, if you
have one, share it.
And now, should you guard
your problems?
I think those days of guarding
problems are gone.
They've gone by because of
things like OpenCourseWare,
putting problem sets online.
It's just not possible anymore
to guard problems.
I'm not sure it was
ever a good idea.
But now it's not
even practical.
So everything is online, all
from the previous year.
So the problems can't
be guarded.
And it's not practical to make
up a whole set of new good
problems for the next year.
You'll never sleep.
So I just trust the students not
to cheat by looking at the
old solution sets.
And if you're grading, that's
yet another reason to minimize
how strict the grading is.
So if the grading is really,
just that they make an effort
and try to learn something,
then there's no benefit to
cheating and looking at
the old solution sets.
So you actually make the
incentive structure so that
they don't need to do all that.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Do you have to change
your problem to a
certain extent in terms
of plagiarism?
PROFESSOR: So the question is,
do I have to change the
problems to a certain extent
to avoid plagiarism?
I don't even care.
I don't even change them.
I think, again, it's sort of
what Adrian has said, is it
their problem if they do it?
And to some extent it
is their problem.
If they're going to cheat and
look at the old solution set
and not acknowledge it.
There's only so much
you can do.
And you then get in an
arms race with them.
You change the problem
to some extent.
But then someone
else makes it.
So they can always
subvert that.
One person can solve the new
problem and give it to
everybody else.
So you have no hope of actually
winning that war,
even if it were a moral
war to try to win.
So I don't even change them.
And I say look, just
acknowledge, just like you
would in science.
I think it's Larry Lessig,
the copyright scholar,
professor of law.
He used to be at Harvard.
Now it's Stanford.
He founded Creative Commons
and various fantastic
copyright projects.
So he said, well, there's a
couple ways to get-- not
compliance--
people to do things.
One is you can do it
through rules.
For example, this is illegal.
You just can't do this.
We'll punish you
if you do this.
The other one is through norm.
So this is just not done.
In our community we just don't
do things like that.
And generally, this kind
of-- not exhortation--
but push works much better
than the punishment kind.
So I just tell them, look, in
science when you grow up and
become a scientist of course you
acknowledge your peers and
people you learn from.
Because that's just polite.
It's just how we are.
We say, please.
We don't say gimme,
gimme, gimme.
I'm working on teaching my
daughter that right now.
She says, daddy read.
Daddy read.
Mommy read.
Elsa read.
I'm like OK, I'm fine
with the Elsa read.
But daddy read, mommy
read, that's nice.
And we love reading.
But how do you ask?
And now she says mommy read
please, daddy read please.
And so it's the start.
So people already learnt
that from young.
So you can tap into that.
Look, how do you act as a
member of the community?
We're social animals.
So you don't have
to put too much
pressure in that direction.
Whereas if you try to do it
through a punishment you have
to work much harder.
The punishment one--
underneath--
has the idea that we don't
trust the students.
Right?
And in that way it's common with
changing the numbers on
the problems set.
It's that we don't trust you so
we're changing the numbers.
So I try to avoid those things
as much as possible and try to
go more towards this.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Has anyone tried
to have problem
sets without solutions?
So then there's no grading.
And then the problem sets
are just for practicing.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, have problem
sets for practice with no
solutions or no grading
on the problem sets?
Have people tried that?
So there's actually
whole educational
systems based on that.
Not so much in America, but
in England, the Oxford and
Cambridge tutorial system.
You're given problems
to work on.
So I was on both sides
of that system.
You're given problems to
work with your tutor.
And they're not graded.
I mean, your tutor helps
you make sure that
you can do the problems.
But everything that's graded
happens at the end.
Well, when I was an
undergraduate it happened at
the end of your entire degree.
There was eight three-hour
exams that counted for
everything.
And nothing else counted.
So it had some craziness.
That time at the end was
pretty stressful.
But before that your tutor
was actually your friend.
And your tutor wasn't the
person doing the exams.
So you would do problems because
you wanted to learn
and your tutor would help you
so that you would do well on
the exam that other people
were setting.
So you had a nice alliance
with your tutor.
AUDIENCE: Does that work well?
PROFESSOR: I would say
it works well.
At MIT it would work great.
Given [INAUDIBLE]
that people are too
overloaded.
And they would say, oh well, if
there's not going to be any
grading at all, I don't have
to do anything, while I'd
really like to do this
problem set.
But I have four other classes
that are making me work 20
hours a week.
And I don't have any time.
So then because of the
other pressures
they might fall away.
But they would like to do it.
So that's why I compromise by
just saying, you have to do
the thing and make an effort.
And then I trust that once they
start trying it they'll
enjoy doing it.
So I tried to make it as light
as I think you can get away
with at MIT, given the
pressures from
all the other teachers.
But in the ideal world I think
that's what we would do here.
There wouldn't be
that pressure.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, in Oxford and
Cambridge it works very well,
provided you have
a good tutor.
And there's many students who
are there just because it's a
thing to do, to go to Oxford
and Cambridge.
But if you factor out those
students who are just there
for the stamp of the place,
for the other students it
works fantastically well.
I mean, the tutorials are
a great discussion time.
You can really kindle people's
curiosity because it's really
not based on grading, it's
based on helping.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: It's so hard to do.
I mean, I don't know
of any comparative
studies within one culture.
And I don't think you could
really do them well between,
say, the English universities
and the American just because
there's so many other social
variables that are so
different like the population
that goes to university, which
universities are talking about
the exam system itself, so I
don't know of any studies that
have been done across cultures
and that I would trust.
And within I don't
know of any.
But it's a good question.
I know studies in general about
rewards, which is that
the more you reward people for
things that they like the less
they like doing them.
So I might give you some
readings for that for very
last penultimate session.
And for the reading that I'm
going to give you for the next
session is going to be about
tutoring, actually.
So I'll put that on
the website today.
OK, questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
of a question.
So I was wondering, if you do
exams or homework problems
throughout the semester, you
can, maybe, also better
monitor how the students develop
compared to having one
big exam on the end.
And then maybe using [INAUDIBLE]
lectures.
PROFESSOR: Right, so having
continuous assessment is one
phrase for it.
It allows you to monitor, make
sure things are going OK.
So all of a sudden you don't
find, oh my god, the person
didn't know anything.
They got a third, which is
like straight D's in your
whole undergraduate.
So in Oxford and Cambridge
things are graded on first,
second, third.
And all of a sudden you had had
no idea the student was
going to get a third,
or they were sick or
something like that.
So I think, yeah.
So homework problems and exams
have a really good purpose in
assessment and helping students
get feedback on how
they're doing as well.
So for that purpose,
grading is useful.
And one solution to that
dilemma-- because I don't like
to grade exactly because
it stresses them
out with the grade--
is to give them the solution
set right away.
So they can get feedback from
the solution set whether they
understood things, not whether
they had a 90 or and 80, but
whether it made sense to them.
And that's, I think, a much
more important thing.
But then the other part of
grading, which is that it's
used publicly--
as part of your record and
written to other people--
that part of grading I
think is not right.
I don't think it's morally right
to, basically, reveal
information about students to
other people without their
permission.
I don't think that should be the
purpose of the university.
But the other purpose of
grading, helping students know
where they are.
And helping us know where they
are so we can help them more,
I think, is a completely
valid purpose.
OK, so there was another
suggestion which was to use as
many non-physics and math
examples as possible.
So I'll try to reform my ways
for the non physicists and
mathematicians.
It's just those come most
naturally for me.
OK, so I think that
was the main--
yes, question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
for evaluating the students or
for teaching the students.
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: Homeworks?
PROFESSOR: Yes, for evaluating
versus for teaching?
AUDIENCE: Yes, because that's
one thing to evaluate, right?
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: It's both.
So there's two, yeah.
So the other purpose is that
they learn and they do things.
That's for sure.
So you want them to do that.
And you can do that in
class and homework.
And the take-home exams that
we had when I was an
undergraduate had that
purpose too.
You spent 24 hours really
learning stuff.
So that purpose is
very valid too.
But it's also very valid to know
where the students are.
So for example, that basically
closes the feedback loop.
You're doing all this stuff.
And now you're seeing
the result of it.
And you want to know, well,
did any of it take?
Did any of it stick?
And if none of it did, well,
maybe you want to change what
you're doing.
AUDIENCE: Oh, but you
cannot evaluate a
person every week, right?
And that's what drives students
to copy solutions
because they care
about the grade.
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's
why distinguish
two senses of evaluate.
There's evaluate
for the purpose
of helping the students.
And there's evaluate for the
purpose of publishing their
grades elsewhere.
And it's the publishing
their grades elsewhere
that worries them.
So you want to minimize
that part.
And you want to do as much
evaluation towards helping
them as possible.
So a solution set-- for example,
one thing you can do
is say OK, here's the
solution set.
Ask me about anything
that's confusing.
And then you can put some of
the responsibility for this
evaluation onto them so
it's self evaluation.
But you're still using the
homework for evaluation.
It's just you're not
trying to say look,
that's the main thing.
I'm going to use that to tell
everyone else about it.
That's what worries them
and produces copying.
So you want to minimize that
as much as possible.
And it's hard.
And that's the subject of the
political obstacles to
educational change session
that'll be in the
second-to-last lecture.
OK, so yeah, I don't pretend
any of these have easy
answers, unfortunately.
Oh, there was another
suggestion, which is that I
make a web forum where people
can ask questions afterwards.
Because it's hard sometimes
think of a
question on the fly.
And that's true.
And the problem is it's not easy
to make web forms on the
MIT.edu site.
So I'll try to figure out
a way to do that.
But for security reasons you
can't really easily make web
forms that just append to a
file or do something like
that, although I'm going to
look into it and see what
workarounds I can find.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
scripts?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you can
use scripts at MIT.edu.
So I have to figure out
how to use that.
But yeah, I had that in
the back of my mind.
But thanks for pointing
that out.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What about forms?
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: Forms?
PROFESSOR: Forms?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so then
you get email.
So the only problem with that is
that you get a ton of spam.
So there are all these spam
bots that float around and
just fill out forms and send
junk emails all the time.
So maybe that can be filtered
out and it's not so bad.
So but yeah, that's one of the
few things you can do on
MIT.edu, directly on
the web.MIT.edu.
So there's a very
solutions to it.
I'll try to think of something
around that because it is a
good suggestion.
OK.